hello everyone
my name is andrew delam director of
distributed systems engineering
here at wolfram research and today i'm
going to talk to you about
wolfram application server it's
something new we're cooking up for you
for basically
another way to bring your wolfram
language content to the web
so what is wolfram application server
well from application server is a
platform for hosting
active web content developed with wilson
language
kind of features being scalable
highly available stateful restful
architecture containerized using docker
and built using uh managed cluster
technology
in our case kubernetes so basically it's
a
modern server architecture
for deploying wolfram language content
at scale
so why why might you want to choose that
well i mean if you've
been if you're familiar at all with some
of our various web offerings
um you know some of you may have used
are familiar with web mathematica
uh you know we also have now
an open source web server
very basic web server
we also have wolfram cloud and
enterprise public cloud
and basically where application server
sits is kind of in the middle between
these two
so on the one hand you have a basic you
know a very simple web server that you
can get
you know hosts one kernel one web server
it's uh good for trying stuff out or
maybe hosting a very small application
that you
you know it's useful but it doesn't
necessarily have to scale or have the
availability
on the other end you've got something
like enterprise public cloud
which is another way to host content but
it also offers you
the wolfram language notebooks
interactive sessions and a whole host of
features for letting people you know use
wolfram language online and using the
full sort of whole suite of notebook
online if so if you don't need that much
yet you still want to host some kinds of
wolfram language content particularly
things like
apis and forms which i'll show in a
minute
then this is a thing for you in
particular
if you need to host these in a situation
where you're going to have a lot of
usage a lot of load or it's a mission
critical application you want to make
sure
that that's always going to be available
that you're you know that it's not
that if there's a problem that uh you
know
the cluster management system is gonna
is gonna keep this thing running for you
it's gonna give you you know your high
availability solution
so that's kind of the reason why maybe
you choose wolfram application server
rather
relative to some of these other other
products that
you know that we also offer
so in talking about from application
server i just want to go over a few
key concepts that will help you
understand how it works and
kind of understand a little bit later
when i demonstrate some of the tools for
using wolf at wolfram application server
there are basically three main things
that kind of
are you know concepts or things that are
part of the server
the first thing that i'm going to talk
about is a resource resource is really
simple that's the thing that's
your actual code or it could be you know
something like html or other static
resources these are the things that are
going to be served up
by the wolfram application workload
application server to your end user
so it could be active web elements which
are things
like api function that actually are you
know computed using wolfram language
you can also host static content like i
said like html so that you can even
if you want to you can build a whole
website
inside of application server it isn't i
wouldn't necessarily go that far
because it's optimized really to serve
uh wolfram language content um but you
can
you can add to that the second concept
is something we call
an end point so the resource is
something
that is served up but the endpoint makes
it addressable
so we've separated out you know the
content
from the the resource locator so
when you define an endpoint you map a
path externally
that your cust you know that your
customer can use
to the resource itself and that is nice
because uh we'll see how
you can use uh resources endpoints to
sort of
um make things more convenient for uh
doing things like versioning or fixing
bugs or
going back and forth between you know
different versions of an application
and then finally we have the node file
the node file is any file that lives
on each of the nodes or in
case of kubernetes world they talked
about pods you know each instance of an
application server
you may need to have resources that are
co-located i mean
for instance if you have wolfram
language packages that you want
the kernel wants to read those is going
to want to read those from a file system
that needs to be
on the actual hardware or in the virtual
hardware or in the virtual
hardware that is running the application
server so that you would use a node file
now a node file is something that is not
directly accessible
by a customer it's sort of internal use
stuff so these are the three
sort of key concepts to help you
understand
what wolfram language server you know
wolfram application
server is doing uh
this is the general architecture of the
application server
um the heart of it is what we call the
active web
active web elements server this is built
on top of what we're calling web kernel
this is sort of
the evolution of the
same technology that we've been using to
power web mathematica
so uh we can if you've
used web mathematica before we can
support msps and we can also
support whatever we call our more modern
way of developing web content things
like api function form function etc http
response
um so we have
a kernel manager embedded in this
application
this active web balance server and this
is what your
you know your users or your customers
are talking to
in order to get content from you now in
order to support
making and deploying content onto the
application server we have
several supporting uh microservices
that allow you to basically deal with
the that con those
that various kind of content i talked
about um we have something called the
resource manager which provides an api
for creating and modifying and removing
resources we have an endpoint manager
which is response which has an api to
allow you to create and remove
endpoints to map to your resources and
we have a node files manager for
creating
and distributing node files you know in
the back end
although you don't ever actually
interact directly with these things
we have to have a storage service which
is an abstraction over
persistent storage it can be uh you know
we have several choices there
if you were lying on amazon that could
be your amazon s3
if you're on your own hardware we have
some you know we can run something
called mineos which sort of emulates
s3 and then you and then you know
provides a sort of an object store
again you don't interact directly with
that but you need persistent storage
and you know these various components uh
talk to that
we also have what we call the streaming
service again
this is sort of the communication hub
basically this entire
you know this entire application is
driven
by messages so as you create resources
and create endpoints
or node files you put them in the
storage then you send messages and then
the active web element server
is able to get those messages and
know what's on you know what's what's
available and
and be able to know where to find
various resources that it needs
so you put this whole thing together
that's
wolfram application server when all
these pieces are working
you're able to create and deploy and
present to your users
wolfram language content
so i'm going to start let me just start
with very simple
demonstration let me just
some of these various features so we
have a packet
we load with wolfram application server
packets
uh it defines a service interface so
it's using our service
connect and service execute functions
so when we create this object basically
this is recording information about
the server you're on and i'm currently
talking to our internal test server
and right now yeah there's nothing on it
because i cleaned it up
so let's go ahead so right now i have a
basically a server with nothing on it
i'm going to go ahead
and just deploy a really simple
application it's the
pretty much your obligatory hello
whatever program
the first program we learn in any
language
and notice it creates what's called a
service deployment
now
they call this information i can call
information on the service deployment
object and it tells me various things
so you notice i created an endpoint
called hello
i created a resource which i put under
in a subdirectory so you know
people know it's me this is the resource
type in this case is an active
web element because it's an api function
it means that the kernel is going to do
you know processing on it and you know
things like mime type we don't worry
about
pool name the default is public
it is possible to configure application
server to run multiple pools
if you want to like divide up your
workload between multiple pools in the
kernel manager you can do that
not necessary so we just pick out the
default and also you can set a timeout
you know if there's some if it's
concerned about whatever you're
deploying
being a long-running computation and
maybe you want it you know it's possible
for users to input
uh data that would cause a very long one
long-running
computation you can of course set a
timeout here so that
it won't run forever and just
show you that this is working so i
send out a query and you'll notice
that in the query i set name mr world
and we got back
hello world
i can do the same thing if i go to a web
browser
and you'll notice again give it
parameter
get hello world back so that's being
served up
by the wolfram application server so
if you want to get that's getting
content onto your wolfram application
server
it's one step so it can be just that
easy
there we go give it a little more
details so we also have some api
functions
for looking at various
information about things so i noticed
i'd set up this hello endpoint so we
have a
endpoint information this gives me a
little more information it's hello and
this tells me the research
the resource that is pointing to
i can get information about the resource
itself again we saw this before
i can actually get the contents of the
file so this is the little
string contents hello world
and that's basically it so since i'm
done with this one it was a trivial
application if i want to clean it up
i can actually just use this and
now i've removed that from the server
so now i'd like to go through the
process in a little more depth give you
a little more fingering
find grain control over various um
parts of this so again i'll use service
deploy to create
a service so what this one does is
it creates a forum where if you enter
any sort of date
it will give you back the day
of that date so okay modestly
interesting
so we try it out here so
and for those of you who are interested
i was born on a sunday okay
so
now if i like maybe i want to have an
alternate way
an alternate path to getting to that
same
um same content so here i
called this endpoint day of week maybe i
want to call it
this day so if people want to try an
alternate uh way you maybe if you
want to try this one or people have
different ideas about what that should
be
i can add an end point and we'll notice
if i go up here
i've gone to this day it's the same
thing
is it
i don't know yeah there we go
bonus points if you know what that date
is it was also on a sunday at least in
the modern calendar
so we've created two different ways to
access the same content
by deploying multiple endpoints to the
same
resource
right so there we go yeah that's all
right
lots of place
so now that's interesting but
it's not all but you know let's let's
jazz up this um
this application just a little bit i'm
going to use some content from wolfram
alpha
this talk may include optional extras
um so i'm going to define this function
you know about this date it's going to
query wolfman alpha
and give me some more info give me some
more information about the date and then
return it as an image so that i can
display it on the web page
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
deploy this as a resource
now in this case here's my form page
it's going to use this function
now so far i've just created a resource
i haven't created an endpoint
so i don't neces i can't yet access this
new thing now
here's a little information about it
now one of the things that's interesting
and kind of to note
is when i deployed this resource you'll
notice when i get the contents here you
see a bunch of this blah blah
you notice i didn't have to type i
didn't have to say anything about this
function definition i defined this
function
i deployed it and you kind of know in
here you'll notice in here in some
various
uh information that
we have basically the definition of
about this
date so by default when you deploy
a resource any dependencies that you
have
will be figured out and all that code
will be inserted
into your application which is quite
nice you know if you
if you if you're working in a notebook
you have a bunch of code a bunch of
functions and you finally kind of
get it to what you want you just have to
deploy this function
and underneath it all we'll sort it all
out and deploy everything you need so
that
when you go ahead and
close that so when we create this new
when we create an endpoint to this
it's just going to work so notice in
this case i'm going to
change the end point this day
to point to my new resource which i
deployed up here as about day so that's
the this is a different resource than
before
but it's going to have i'm updating the
endpoint
so if we go back here
and in this case if i send the form
again
you see that now i get this nice wolf
amount
alpha output of here's the day so it was
a sunday
to various calendars if you're
interested
there's the islamic calendar for anyone
who knows it
uh how long ago it was and
for everyone who said battle of hastings
give yourself one point you are a winner
uh so look so now we have a kind of more
interesting
form and again
all i just deployed a resource
i changed an endpoint and now i have a
different
you know i have a simple endpoint and a
more complex endpoint
kind of illustrates some of the
usefulness of separating the resource
from the endpoint
because with the resource
i mean one of the things you can do for
instance let's say you're you want to
update you're working on a new version
of some api
and you want to deploy it you deploy it
as you can maybe
deploy you know you can deploy the
resources with a different name
than the previous one you know maybe
just like resource dot one resource dot
two whatever
some convention you wanna follow and
then all you have to do is change the
end point
and if you know worse comes to worse you
realize
maybe there's a bug in it or you don't
like the way the new api is working
it's just a matter of re-mapping the
endpoint back to the old resource
and you immediately restore your old
functionality
so breaking up you know a lot of
convenient things about
breaking up resources and endpoints and
it makes it
can you know things like version
controlling versions of your apis
are one of the things that you get uh by
doing this
boy i managed to keep hitting the wrong
thing
let's go to the last slide and go back
there we go almost done all right so
so far
um we've looked at creating content and
just deploying it
straight from a notebook obviously if
you have a more complicated application
something that has a lot of code
and you want to use it you want to
to package it all up and then have
things access that package
uh we can do that so i've created
this package is not very interesting but
it shows you a package file it has this
function it's
basically the same about this day
function i deployed before but now it's
you know sort of done a nice package
with some messaging
and what i can do is
i can deploy this package as a node file
and we'll notice now that if i ask for
the node files i'll get this now again
this isn't content that your users are
going to access directly
what's happening is this package is now
being distributed
to all the all the pods in the
kubernetes cluster
and i can deploy a resource and in this
case
i'm going to need to load the package
and then call the function
but i'll go ahead and do that so now
notice i'm updating
my about this day resource to have
new content which is a form page that's
going to rely on this package
for this functionality now i haven't
loaded this package into my session
because remember what i said that by
default um
will all the definitions will be copied
in and
included as part of this distribution so
you want to be a little careful if
you're using packages
that you either you don't have the me
that you clear your contacts before you
deploy this and then of course you fully
qualify the name here
or there is an option that you can
include in this um
i haven't tried this before but if you
do this
that's another way it says don't
actually try to get the definitions
let's see if this works
that seems to work good all right and
now
i'm going to reroute my endpoint
maybe not already and then we can load
this one more time
talking to alpha and here we go so
still works so in this case i've shown
how that you can use
a package i'm not going to demonstrate
this here but
the obviously next question is well look
i have a very large package i don't want
to have to load it every time
you know i call my function i just want
every kernel
to load that package
when uh you know when it's when it's
initialized and then i can just use this
and you can do that it's very simple we
have a convention if you deploy
if you deploy on a file an init.wl or an
it dot
m file as a node file
to i think it's dot wolfram kernel
then that will be loaded that will be
read as a kernel initialization file
so it's possible then to create
initialization files so that every time
a kernel is created
it's going to load your package so again
if you have a very large application you
can deploy it as a package
you can then include initialization code
that will always load that
package and then when your actual api
served up it'll all be loaded warmed up
ready to go
so we've got that covered as well
all right so that kind of ends you know
the basic features i pretty much hit
all of the apis the main high points of
the api
and how you create content and
manage it on the wolfram application
server i'm just going to be nice here
and clean up
so at this point i think i can stop
and we have a few minutes i can find my
web browser
here there we go
um if we have
let's see here
if anyone has any questions um
chat is a good way to do it refresh the
page changer okay
you have a question in the zoom chat how
does this scale
how does it scale so
the way um the um
wolfram application server is managed
through kubernetes and kubernetes will
manage the scaling
the basic deal is you
can you purchase
licenses for wolfram engines and then
you can configure
your kubernetes cluster to run as many
instances of the application
you know active web element server
as you have kernel so each act you can
configure each active web elements
server pod to have a pool
of so many kernels i think we run four
to six
and that's kind of you should configure
that based on
the hardware that's going to be hosting
uh
your cluster then you can conf then the
um
kubernetes can be configured to run up
to
n of these pods in terms of how
kubernetes decides
how many pods it needs to run it depends
we're playing around with different
things right now that what we're using
basically is we're looking
at you know cpu load so
uh if you know the cpu load of a certain
pod it goes over a certain threshold
then that's a signal to kubernetes to
say it should fire up another pod and it
will and then kubernetes itself has a
load balancer
kubernetes itself offers all sorts of um
methods for being able to uh determine
how
you want to scale pods we're we're still
looking we're doing some experiments on
our own see if we can do better than
just straight up um
uh cpu usage and memory usage but
um you know i think in some sense
it's going to ultimately the way you
want to scale is going to depend
really on the kind of load you get for
instance if you have
if your application is very cpu heavy
then that's going to be one
you want to scale on that if it's very
say i o bound like it's doing a lot of
calling out the databases or reading
files from disk or whatever
then that's not a good measure and you
may need a different kind of script
using you know ultimately if you want to
use wolfram application server
effectively you
are going to have to have some
kubernetes expertise
the good news is all the popular kids
are using kubernetes so
if you haven't if you're not doing that
already or if you know people in your
organization don't have those skills
they're very good skills to have and
they're desirable so you won't you know
if you want to use this
you need them but they're good to have
okay let's see if we have some other
actual questions questions
oh can i call it uh can i comment on the
cost of
applications relative to wpc
so cost i don't know what the final
pricing is yet
basically the pricing of application
server
is going to um
is going to be based on number of kernel
licenses
so i think that the relative cost
whether it's
more or less or the same per kernel
compared to
to the private cloud i don't know what
the final decision on that
is i think i think there is probably a
discount relative to the two since
obviously epc
provides more features
all right uh does anyone health
does anyone else have any questions for
me at this time
all right well i'm like almost perfectly
on time
so if there are no more questions um i
think we can go ahead
and end this meeting so last chance
all right ben thank you everyone i
appreciate you taking the time um
hopefully this uh piques your interest i
think it's a
i think it's a pretty cool new thing uh
just so you know
we're not we're in beta right now
we're very close to release if you are
interested in
trying this out definitely talk to our
salespeople about the beta
the truth is by the time you're ready
probably to
deploy your application you know
to the world will be in release so the
fact that i just said beta
hopefully shouldn't scare you away if
you're interested you know
we can get this to you and get you to
try it out all right
so thank you very much